Jake:就是你如果腰斩的话不就不能拨了吗
Jake: I mean, if you get cut in half, it can't be broadcast.
Lucia: 你好认真的在思索这个可能性啊
Lucia: You're seriously considering this possibility, huh?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:你真的不把我的命当命
Alice: You really don't value my life.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你太不重视员工的身心健康了
Lucia: You don't value the well-being of your employees at all.
Lucia: 老板
Lucia: Boss.
Jake:嗯那还是暂时暂时
Jake: Hmm, well, for now, for now.
Lucia: 这是洗洁精吗
Lucia: Is this dish soap?
Alice:嗯嗯
Alice: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:我们不要腰斩啊
Jake: Let's not get cut in half.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha.
Lucia: 暂时保留到
Lucia: Temporarily keep it.
Alice:嗯暂时
Alice: Yes, temporarily.
Lucia: 保留到录制完作为于心节目是吗
Lucia: Keep it until the recording is done as part of the show, right?
Alice:小哥哥你
Alice: Hey dude, you...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 小哥哥你哈哈哈哈哈哈哈笑死
Lucia: Hey dude, you... hahahahahahaha, so funny
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈对不起我笑点低哈哈
Lucia: Haha, sorry, I have a low laugh threshold, haha
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:哎喂
Jake: Hey, listen
Jake:哎我我那个要扫房间
Jake: Hey, I need to clean the room
Jake:然后你你你这个屋子我就这么扫了
Jake: So, I'm just going to clean this room like this
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:哈哈行行挺有艺术感
Jake: Haha, okay, it's quite artistic
Lucia: 他是在说修硕吗
Lucia: Is he talking about Shure?
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:好嗯拜拜
Jake: Okay, bye
Lucia: 嗯我说他还在说修硕吗
Lucia: Hmm, I said, is he still talking about Shure?
Alice:哪吒啊
Alice: Nezha*
Lucia: 宝你的衣服洗了吗
Lucia: Babe, did you wash your clothes?
Lucia: 啊这么快
Lucia: Ah, so fast
Alice:洗了
Alice: Yes
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 好的吧
Lucia: Okay then
Alice:我本来想吃完饭再洗的
Alice: I was planning to wash them after dinner
Alice:他一直在这催我说我懒
Alice: But he kept urging me, saying I'm lazy
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:就已经洗完了嗯
Jake: So, they are already washed, huh?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 我在给上面抹洗洁精
Lucia: I'm applying dish soap on top
Alice:真是醉了
Alice: I'm so done with this
Alice:你把这个粉撒到这里面
Alice: You pour this powder in here
Lucia: 要不我还是用洗衣机洗一遍算了
Lucia: Or maybe I'll just use the washing machine again
Lucia: 因为刚那个掉下来的他
Lucia: Because it just fell off
Jake:可以对
Jake: Sure, go ahead
Jake:啊 15分钟不算十
Jake: Ah, 15 minutes doesn't count as ten
Jake:十十五分钟算什么
Jake: Ten, fifteen minutes, what's that?
Alice:磕一下磕哒磕哒
Alice: Tap, tap, tap
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Lucia: 还可以选择30分钟模式
Lucia: You can also choose the 30-minute mode
Alice:OK
Alice: OK
Lucia: 相当于你在之前的时间损耗上
Lucia: Equivalent to your previous time loss
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 增加了100%的成本
Lucia: Increased by 100% of the cost
Jake:呵呵好的
Jake: Hehe, okay
Lucia: 重点不在于绝对值
Lucia: The key is not the absolute value
Lucia: 而在于它的百分比
Lucia: But the percentage
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Hmm, got it
Lucia: 投资学告诉我们哈投资学
Lucia: Investment studies tell us, investment studies
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Jake:这个能带来什么收益
Jake: What kind of returns can this bring?
Lucia: 收益收益就是你的裤子会变干净
Lucia: Returns, the return is your pants will be cleaner
Lucia: 也许吧
Lucia: Maybe
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 但是还有一些风险就是没洗干净
Lucia: But there are risks, like not washing clean enough
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 我们要尽量保持这个风险可控
Lucia: We need to try to keep this risk controllable
Lucia: 也就是说
Lucia: That means
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 尽量不要把饭渣掉在自己身上
Lucia: Try not to drop food on yourself
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss
Alice:这几天为数不多的桌子干净的环节
Alice: These few days, the few times the table was clean
Alice:是不是都是我创造的
Alice: Wasn't that all because of me?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Alice:卧槽吓死我了
Alice: Wow, that scared me
Jake:这是
Jake: This is
Jake:这这没没说错啊
Jake: This, this is not wrong
Jake:为什么掉下来了
Jake: Why did it fall down?
Alice:这个地是不是可以叫那个清洁的那个
Alice: Should we call that cleaning person for the floor?
Jake:对我在叫他们
Jake: Yes, I'm calling them
Alice:OK
Alice: OK
Jake:不但是这个地我们其实
Jake: Not just the floor, we actually
Jake:呃他今天明天都可以搞
Jake: Uh, he can do it today or tomorrow
Alice:哦那明天也行
Alice: Oh, tomorrow is fine too
Jake:或者我们走了都可以搞
Jake: Or we can leave it for them to do later
Alice:只要反正
Alice: As long as
Jake:这个地不重要
Jake: The floor isn't important
Alice:只要你看着不难受无所谓
Alice: As long as it doesn't bother you, it's fine
Jake:嗯确实不怎么好受
Jake: Hmm, it's not really comfortable
Jake:但是
Jake: But
Alice:但是可以装作看不见
Alice: But you can pretend you didn't see it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:你可以不出来
Alice: You don't have to come out.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵确实
Jake: Hehe, indeed.
Lucia: you shall not pass
Lucia: You shall not pass.
Alice:我妈就有点洁癖
Alice: My mom is a bit of a clean freak.
Alice:就是地上就拖的拖
Alice: She mops the floor constantly.
Alice:拖完地之后地上有水痕反光
Alice: After mopping, there are water marks that reflect light.
Alice:被他看见他都很难受
Alice: If he sees it, he feels uncomfortable.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:然后他就老嫌我
Alice: Then he always complains about me.
Alice:干就是干家务啥的就不细致
Alice: Saying that I don't do housework carefully.
Alice:说我邋遢
Alice: Says I'm messy.
Alice:确实是实话
Alice: It's true, actually.
Alice:我确实很邋遢
Alice: I am really messy.
Alice:然后但是我就让他你就不能不看吗
Alice: But I tell him, can't you just not look?
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Lucia: 我怎么觉得我上次搓的也是这条裤子
Lucia: Why do I feel like I scrubbed these pants last time too?
Lucia: 我的AI收集到最重要的数据就是
Lucia: The most important data my AI has collected is
Lucia: 我经常来搓这条裤子
Lucia: I often scrub these pants.
Lucia: 他肯定会以为
Lucia: He will definitely think
Lucia: 这条裤子对我来说有什么
Lucia: These pants have something
Lucia: 特别严特别
Lucia: Very serious, very
Lucia: 怎么说呢
Lucia: How should I say it?
Lucia: 独特的意义
Lucia: Unique significance.
Lucia: 我才会这么专心致志的洗他
Lucia: That's why I'm so dedicated to washing them.
Jake:他是看到这个裤子就要搓一会
Jake: He sees these pants and just has to scrub for a while.
Lucia: 对看到之后就不是
Lucia: Yes, when he sees them, it's just...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Alice:看见这个裤子就要搓一搓
Alice: He sees these pants and just has to scrub them.
Lucia: 最后他会建
Lucia: In the end, he will build...
Lucia: 起这样一个链接吗
Lucia: ...such a connection, right?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哦怪不得
Lucia: Oh, no wonder.
Lucia: 怪不得游戏里有那么多人工智障模型
Lucia: No wonder there are so many artificial intelligence models in games.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我我我玩使命召唤五五的时候因为哎
Lucia: When I played Call of Duty 5, because...
Jake:嗯嗯哎
Jake: Hmm hmm hey
Lucia: 你在哪里
Lucia: Where are you?
Jake:哈哈哈环绕似的
Jake: Haha, it's like it's surrounding us.
Lucia: 哈哈环绕机
Lucia: Haha, surround sound
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:3D的 5D的
Alice: 3D, 5D
Lucia: 我玩视频召唤5的时候
Lucia: When I was playing Call of Duty 5
Lucia: 因为他那个比较老嘛
Lucia: Because it's kind of old
Lucia: 他好多年前的游戏
Lucia: It's a game from many years ago
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 所以就有时候穿模会穿的很奇怪
Lucia: So sometimes the textures glitch in weird ways
Lucia: 就比如说我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: For example, when I blow up an enemy
Lucia: 然后这个可以
Lucia: Then this can
Jake:没关系没关系啊
Jake: It's alright, it's alright
Lucia: 这个会啊
Lucia: This will happen
Lucia: OK就我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: Okay, so after I blow up an enemy
Lucia: 没事反正是虚拟人物
Lucia: It's fine since it's a virtual character
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Lucia: 然后就是就是那个靴子就会浮起来
Lucia: Then the boots just float up
Lucia: 在半空中停留
Lucia: And stay suspended in mid-air
Lucia: 他没有落到地上
Lucia: They don't fall to the ground
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 就就那样卡在那里
Lucia: They just get stuck there
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 然后我当时卧倒
Lucia: Then I went prone
Lucia: 因为我害怕
Lucia: Because I was scared
Lucia: 就是对方射击我
Lucia: That the enemy would shoot me
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 我卧倒之后
Lucia: After I went prone
Lucia: 我就看到刚被我打死的敌人的靴子
Lucia: I saw the boots of the enemy I just killed
Lucia: 飘在我的面前
Lucia: Floating in front of me
Jake:哈哈哈哈悬浮一个靴子
Jake: Hahaha, a floating boot
Lucia: 好恐怖啊
Lucia: So scary
Alice:小姐姐我要洗个手
Alice: Miss, I need to wash my hands
Lucia: 对真的是悬浮一个靴子
Lucia: Yeah, it was really a floating boot
Alice:哇哦you so勤奋
Alice: Wow, you are so diligent
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright
Alice:OK拿个纸你
Alice: Okay, get a tissue
Alice:你是把我的歌停了吗
Alice: Did you stop my song?
其他人：没有它自己停的
Others: It stops on its own.
Alice:我靠神经病啊
Alice: Oh my God, are you crazy?
Lucia: 可以了就这样吧
Lucia: It's fine, let's just leave it like this.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:重新给你放吧
Alice: Let me play it for you again.
Alice:一到那就是卡壳
Alice: It always gets stuck at that part.
Lucia: （歌词）大鱼在梦境的
Lucia: (lyrics) The big fish in dreams.
Lucia: （歌词）缝隙里
Lucia: (lyrics) In the gaps.
Lucia: （歌词）游过凝望你
Lucia: (lyrics) Swims by, gazing at you.
Lucia: 我来扫吧
Lucia: I'll sweep it up.
Lucia: 我裤子脱好了
Lucia: I've taken off my pants.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Alice:这地上粘的像泥一样
Alice: The floor is sticky like mud.
Lucia: （歌词）着你心碎的轮廓
Lucia: (lyrics) The outline of your broken heart.
Jake:哎等会等会
Jake: Hey, wait, wait.
Jake:我这一圈相机没开所以
Jake: I didn't turn on this row of cameras, so...
Lucia: 一些相机
Lucia: Some cameras.
Lucia: 所以啊
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Jake:一会你先把这个扫把到门口等着
Jake: First, you sweep to the door and wait there.
Jake:然后我开
Jake: Then I'll turn it on.
Jake:我开一完之后就开始扫
Jake: Once I turn it on, you start sweeping.
Lucia: 行好
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Jake:好对
Jake: Good, right.
Alice:没开吗扫
Alice: Didn't turn it on, sweep.
Jake:扫下有叫什么
Jake: Sweep it, what is it called...
Lucia: 扫扫扫
Lucia: Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Jake:扫把扫帚下牛垃圾
Jake: Sweep the broom, trash.
Jake:哈哈听
Jake: Haha, listen.
Lucia: 等一下我要把扫把放到哪
Lucia: Wait, where should I put the broom?
Lucia: 你刚刚说随便一个地方
Lucia: You just said anywhere.
Jake:就是进场的
Jake: Just at the entrance.
Jake:进场就行了
Jake: It's fine at the entrance.
Alice:虽然这个没有录
Alice: Even though it didn't record.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Alice:但是这个不是录上了嗯
Alice: But this part got recorded, right?
Jake:这个这个没问题
Jake: This, this is fine.
Jake:对就开一下子
Jake: Yes, just turn it on.
Alice:好的那我可以嗑瓜子了吗
Alice: Alright, can I eat sunflower seeds now?
Jake:可以哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, haha.
Alice:可以的哈哈哈
Alice: Sure, hahaha.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 往地下扔
Lucia: Throw it on the ground.
Jake:嗑瓜子哈哈哈挺好挺好
Jake: Eating sunflower seeds, hahaha, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈给他多制造一下
Lucia: Hahaha, create more for him.
Alice:我我不咋地上
Alice: I, I don't really...
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:等会等会你你一会再水滴润
Jake: Wait, wait, you can drop them later.
Jake:就是一会我们造成一个一一会
Jake: We'll create a scene in a bit.
Alice:我我不扔地上
Alice: I, I won't throw them on the ground.
Lucia: 没事反正会扫掉的
Lucia: It's okay, they'll get swept up anyway.
Jake:就是你一边嗑瓜子然后一边往地上
Jake: Just eat the seeds and throw them on the ground.
Jake:然后就在旁边扫
Jake: Then someone will sweep them.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 好奇怪的场景啊
Lucia: Such a strange scene.
Alice:这样会不会给我打上一个人品
Alice: Won't that give me a bad reputation?
Alice:人品低劣的标签
Alice: A label of low character.
Lucia: 那你先嗑一会我再进来扫
Lucia: Then you eat for a bit, I'll sweep later.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈要不然
Lucia: Hahaha, otherwise...
Lucia: 有一种就是这两个动作同时发声
Lucia: Both actions happening simultaneously is strange.
Lucia: 就很奇怪
Lucia: It's just weird.
Lucia: 但如果发声完再发声就同时发声
Lucia: If both happen at the same time, it's really strange.
Jake:那就等会
Jake: Then wait.
Alice:同时发生
Alice: Simultaneously.
Alice:好像是我这人故意找点事什么的
Alice: It looks like I'm deliberately causing trouble.
Lucia: 哈哈那我跟你一起嗑吧
Lucia: Haha, then I'll eat seeds with you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:要不来吧
Alice: Let's do it.
Jake:等会再嗑喝等会再磕等会再喝
Jake: Wait, eat later, eat later, drink later.
Jake:忍忍一下忍一下忍
Jake: Hold on, just hold on.
Lucia: 忍一下
Lucia: Hold on.
Jake:一下
Jake: Just a bit.
Alice:我就不能一直嗑吗
Alice: Can't I just keep eating?
Jake:你可以啊你可以一直嗑
Jake: You can, you can keep eating.
Alice:来吧大爷
Alice: Let's go, man.
Jake:来了我怕你嗑饱了嘛
Jake: Come on, I'm just worried you'll get full.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 还有健胃消食片呢
Lucia: There's digestive tablets too.
Jake:哈哈哈那你先吃
Jake: Hahaha, then you eat first.
Lucia: 哈哈哈人均造梗大师
Lucia: Hahaha, everyone here is a meme master.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: （歌词）执子手吹散苍茫茫烟波
Lucia: (Lyrics) Hold your hand, scatter the vast mist.
Lucia: 嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm mm mm.
Lucia: （歌词）已经太辽阔
Lucia: (Lyrics) It's already too vast.
Alice:小姐姐太勤奋了爱上了
Alice: This girl is so diligent, I'm in love.
Lucia: 这算不算一种义工呢
Lucia: Does this count as some kind of volunteer work?
Alice:加工资吧老板
Alice: Give us a raise, boss.
Jake:晚上吃点好的
Jake: Let's have something good for dinner.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How about it?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:就到门口那个彩票店旁边
Jake: Just next to the lottery shop at the entrance.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:彩票店旁边
Alice: Next to the lottery shop.
Alice:吃狗唉不对
Alice: Eating dog... no wait.
Jake:哎不对这是什么东西
Jake: Hey, wait, what's that?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈是什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what is that?
Alice:对不起哈哈哈这个这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Sorry, hahaha, this, this, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈吃什么
Jake: Hahaha, what are we eating?
Alice:呃吃狗店的
Alice: Uh, from the dog shop.
Lucia: 我不去
Lucia: I'm not going.
Alice:小食
Alice: Snacks.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我在家看家
Lucia: Hahaha, I'll stay home and watch the house.
Alice:看门有我们的CP狗就可以了
Alice: Our CP dog can watch the house.
Alice:你要跟我们一起
Alice: You should come with us.
Lucia: 我给CP狗喂俩吃了
Lucia: I'll feed the CP dog some food.
Jake:昨天那俩不是卖了吗
Jake: Didn't we sell those two yesterday?
Lucia: 没有啊
Lucia: No, we didn't.
Jake:没带走是吧
Jake: They didn't take them, right?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Jake:没有好嘞
Jake: Okay then.
Jake:净赚这黑店
Jake: This place is pure profit, a shady shop.
Jake:纯黑店这是
Jake: Purely shady.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈近赚纯黑店
Jake: Hahaha, pure profit, shady shop.
Lucia: 净赚
Lucia: Pure profit.
Lucia: 不是咱们的那个coin呢
Lucia: Where's our coin by the way?
Lucia: 上链那个coin不是说要
Lucia: Didn't you say to put that coin on the chain?
Jake:但是他们不是购买了吗对吧
Jake: But didn't they buy it, right?
Jake:购买了商品应该带走
Jake: If they bought the goods, they should take them.
Lucia: 之前不是说那个coin要
Lucia: Didn't you say before that the coin...
Lucia: 就是啊对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Jake:对统计一下
Jake: Yeah, let's count it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:但是统计的那个人发烧了
Jake: But the person who was counting got a fever.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 那我创建一个钱包吧
Lucia: Then I'll create a wallet.
Jake:哎可以等他
Jake: Well, you can wait for him.
Lucia: 不是我前两年
Lucia: No, a couple of years ago...
Lucia: 我前两年
Lucia: A couple of years ago...
Lucia: 前两年
Lucia: 那个就是NFT在国内刚很火的时候
Lucia: When NFTs were just getting popular in the country...
Alice:搁这
Alice: Put it here.
Lucia: 我之前是想就是那什么我问你纸
Lucia: I was thinking... I asked you for paper...
Alice:这是
Alice: Here it is.
Alice:纸
Alice: Paper.
Alice:黑色的纸
Alice: Black paper.
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 我那会儿是想创一个钱包的
Lucia: I wanted to create a wallet back then.
Lucia: 然后本来还有几个东西
Lucia: Then I also had a few things...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我想试着上一下链
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是最后让我放弃的原因是什么呢
Lucia: But what made me give up in the end?
Lucia: gaspy太贵了
Lucia: The gas fees were too expensive.
Jake:哦好吧对消耗太大对
Jake: Oh, right, the cost was too high, yeah.
Lucia: 对然后我就没搞
Lucia: Yeah, so I didn't do it.
Lucia: 但是既然你们已经商量过了
Lucia: But since you guys have already discussed it...
Lucia: 那我就只需要创一个钱包就行了
Lucia: Then I just need to create a wallet.
Lucia: 创钱包又不要钱
Lucia: Creating a wallet is free.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Lucia: 让我倒过来薅老板羊毛哈哈哈
Lucia: Let me take advantage of the boss, haha.
Jake:十年之后
Jake: Ten years later...
Lucia: 对谁知道呢
Lucia: Yeah, who knows?
Jake:买十十年之后把这套房子买下来
Jake: Buy this house ten years later.
Lucia: 万一十年之后
Lucia: What if ten years later...
Lucia: 你成了下一个艾隆马斯克
Lucia: You've become the next Elon Musk.
Jake:哈OK
Jake: Haha, OK.
Lucia: 那咱这个Coin不就值钱了吗是吧
Lucia: Then our Coin will be worth a lot, right?
Jake:那确实
Jake: Definitely.
Lucia: 那我这个
Lucia: So I...
Alice:个
Alice: Uh...
Lucia: 不能错过这个初始股东的机会
Lucia: Can't miss this chance to be an initial shareholder.
Lucia: 领导苟富贵勿相忘啊
Lucia: Boss, don't forget us when you're rich and powerful.
Jake:哈哈哈必不会
Jake: Haha, I definitely won't.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:相忘的至少
Jake: At least don't forget me.
Alice:这是个甲壳虫
Alice: This is a beetle.
Alice:你知道吗
Alice: You know?
Alice:这是他的尸体
Alice: This is its body.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Lucia: 开了吗
Lucia: Is it on?
Jake:快了
Jake: Almost.
Lucia: 快我迫不及待的想扫地哈哈哈
Lucia: Hurry, I can't wait to start cleaning, haha.
Alice:快了
Alice: Almost.
Jake:还差一个
Jake: Just one more step.
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh, come on.
Lucia: 你要听别的歌吗
Lucia: Do you want to listen to another song?
Alice:你要听别的歌吗
Alice: Do you want to listen to another song?
其他人：行啊
Others: Sure.
Alice:说吧
Alice: Go ahead.
其他人： 嗯随便放吧
Others: Yeah, just play anything.
Alice:你给我指定呗
Alice: Can you choose one for me?
Alice:林俊杰
Alice: JJ Lin.
其他人：不要听腻了
Others: No, we're tired of him.
Alice:那你说名
Alice: Then you name one.
其他人： 嗯
Others: Hmm.
Lucia: 你平常
Lucia: Usually,
Lucia: 你这个衬衣看起来真的特别舒服
Lucia: Your shirt looks really comfortable.
Alice:嗯棉麻的
Alice: Yeah, it's cotton and linen.
Alice:我平时听的
Alice: What I usually listen to...
Alice:你要让我
Alice: If you let me...
Alice:挑歌我得挑半个小时了
Alice: Choose a song, it'll take me half an hour.
Alice:这人比较墨迹
Alice: I'm quite indecisive.
Lucia: 点
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:好说爱你好吗
Alice: Alright, how about "Love You"?
其他人：行
Others: Alright
Alice:就放这这就是这里的嗯
Alice: Just put it here, this is the spot, hmm
Alice:嗯呐
Alice: Yeah
Alice:就是放那的无妨
Alice: It's fine to put it there
Alice:一开始
Alice: At the beginning
Alice:哈不是
Alice: Ha, no
其他人：直接进副歌
Others: Directly into the chorus
Alice:这次绝对进对了
Alice: This time we definitely got it right
Alice:一开始哈哈哈
Alice: At the beginning, hahaha
Lucia: 可以了吗
Lucia: Is it okay now?
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Jake:还有
Jake: There's more
Alice:咋了
Alice: What happened?
Alice:什么受伤了
Alice: What got hurt?
Jake:哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey
Alice:不用了
Alice: No need
Jake:我去
Jake: I'll go
Jake:即将开始
Jake: It's about to start
Alice:关于爱情
Alice: About love
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:好各位各就各位开始磕
Jake: Alright everyone, get ready to start
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 唉怎么那天那个袋子还在这啊
Lucia: Hey, why is that bag still here from the other day?
Jake:哎稍等
Jake: Hey, hold on
Lucia: 还没好吗
Lucia: Not done yet?
Jake:对有一个他有问题
Jake: Yeah, there's an issue with one of them
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Jake:就是这个
Jake: It's this one
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 好失望哦哈哈
Lucia: So disappointed, haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Lucia: 啊哎你可以实时看到回放吗
Lucia: Ah hey, can you see the replay in real-time?
Jake:他要连一会导一会能看到
Jake: It needs to connect for a while, then you can see it
Alice:你还你戴上干嘛
Alice: Why are you still wearing it?
Lucia: i see OK
Lucia: I see, OK
Alice:哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh my god
Alice:真扔出去了
Alice: Really threw it out
Lucia: 因为刚好在那个啥有音乐
Lucia: Because there was music right at that moment
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Great
Jake:好开扫
Jake: Alright, let's start cleaning
Lucia: 可以扫了是吧
Lucia: We can start cleaning, right?
Alice:这样显得我特别没素质说实话
Alice: This makes me look really uncultured, to be honest
Lucia: 没事我一会跟你一块磕
Lucia: It's okay, I'll join you in a bit
Alice:给我打上一个人品低劣的标签
Alice: Just label me as a person of low character
Lucia: 呵不会的
Lucia: Haha, no way
Lucia: 那要不我们想想换个活动
Lucia: How about we think of a different activity?
Alice:无所谓啊
Alice: Whatever
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Haha
Alice:又没认识我
Alice: No one knows me anyway
Alice:这样是不是显得很无理
Alice: Does this make me look rude?
Lucia: 没有啊我觉得这样就是这很正常吧
Lucia: No, I think it's totally normal
Lucia: 应该就就是我
Lucia: It's just me
Lucia: 如果周围没有垃圾桶我就会扔到跳
Lucia: If there's no trash can around, I would throw it on the ground
Alice:嗯但其实这有垃圾桶
Alice: But there is a trash can here
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哦没事
Lucia: Oh, it's fine
Lucia: 我们可以假装他没有我
Lucia: We can pretend it's not there
Lucia: 我们假设
Lucia: Let's assume
Lucia: 哈哈我们假设他没有
Lucia: Haha, let's assume it's not there
Alice:你嗑瓜子吗
Alice: Do you eat sunflower seeds?
Alice:为什么
Alice: Why?
其他人：为什么做文明有理一勾人
Others: Why act civilized and polite?
Alice:你给这一勾上了
Alice: You got hooked on that
Alice:什么意思啊
Alice: What do you mean?
Alice:我嗑瓜子我就不文明了
Alice: Eating sunflower seeds makes me uncivilized?
其他人：没说啊不是这个意思
Others: That's not what we meant
Alice:你不就这意思吗
Alice: Isn't that exactly what you meant?
Alice:一开始一二
Alice: At first, one or two
Alice:那不能喝
Alice: Can't drink that
Alice:那喝给你毒死
Alice: It'll poison you
Alice:给咱婷寻摸个什么
Alice: Let's find something for us
Alice:嗯啥玩意这是
Alice: What is this?
Jake:好我们嗑瓜子大军加一
Jake: Alright, add one more to our sunflower seed army
Alice:冰块
Alice: Ice cubes
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Add one
Jake:来嗑瓜子
Jake: Come eat sunflower seeds
Alice:我俩是你的后勤保卫军
Alice: We are your logistics support team
Lucia: 哦那个是
Lucia: Oh, that is
Lucia: 那个是修硕了
Lucia: That's Shure.
Lucia: 嘿呀哎叮咚
Lucia: Hey ya ding dong.
Lucia: 这应该可以先倒一下
Lucia: We should pour this first.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 我在想我要不要把一些东西寄回去
Lucia: I'm thinking about whether to send some things back.
Jake:可以呀
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 感觉
Lucia: Feels like...
Tasha: 我也要寄
Tasha: I need to send stuff too.
Jake:寄吧好寄
Jake: Go ahead, send it.
Lucia: 我们要收集一下
Lucia: We need to gather some...
Lucia: 寄快递的那个啥吗
Lucia: Are we collecting the shipping supplies?
Alice:那我也带不走啊
Alice: I can't carry it all.
Jake: 可以啊就是顺丰上门呗
Jake: Sure, you can use SF Express to pick it up.
Lucia: 附近有没有快递点
Lucia: Is there a nearby courier?
Lucia: 顺丰太贵了
Lucia: SF Express is too expensive.
Tasha: 充上电了吗
Tasha: Is it charged?
Jake:充上了
Jake: Yes, it's charged.
Jake:那还有什么上门
Jake: So what else can pick up?
Jake:别的应该有上门
Jake: There should be other pickup services.
Lucia: 我们可以去快递点寄
Lucia: We can go to the courier station.
Alice:那也可以
Alice: That works too.
Alice:那也不行东西太多了
Alice: But no, there's too much stuff.
Jake:对拿回来了
Jake: Yeah, got it back.
Jake:今天可厉害了啊
Jake: We did great today.
Jake:昨天昨天早上三个人拿完了一只手
Jake: Yesterday morning, three people picked up everything with one hand.
Lucia: 哦你说取快递
Lucia: Oh, you mean picking up packages.
Lucia: 对我感觉我我我那些东西
Lucia: Yeah, I feel like most of my stuff...
Lucia: 其实大部分的东西还是能放得下
Lucia: Actually, most of my stuff can fit.
Lucia: 但是有有一些东西有点
Lucia: But some things are a bit...
Alice:底下底下啊
Alice: Underneath, underneath.
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't it there?
Alice:地可以
Alice: The floor is okay.
Alice:先不拖吧
Alice: Let's not mop it yet.
Alice:等着明天阿姨来拖
Alice: Wait for the cleaning lady tomorrow.
Lucia: 应该是可以的
Lucia: It should be fine.
Alice:装作看不见
Alice: Pretend we didn't see it.
Alice:我那个地毯我想寄回去
Alice: I want to send that carpet back.
Lucia: 你是寄到学校还是寄到家呀
Lucia: Are you sending it to school or home?
Alice:寄到家学校没地方
Alice: Sending it home, there's no space at school.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Yeah, me too.
Lucia: 我是那个那个小桌子
Lucia: I'm that, that small table.
Lucia: 我想
Lucia: I think...
Alice:那你是不是还得把它拆了呀对
Alice: Shouldn't you take it apart?
Lucia: 因为感觉就用一下就扔掉有点对
Lucia: Because it feels wasteful to use it once and then throw it away.
Lucia: 太可惜了
Lucia: Such a pity.
Alice:我的桌布打算让刘婷给我继承走
Alice: I'm planning to let Liu Ting inherit my tablecloth.
Lucia: 我们就简单的扫一下
Lucia: Let's just do a quick sweep.
Lucia: 要不然的话地上纸有点太多了
Lucia: Otherwise, there's too much paper on the floor.
Lucia: 就是大家会有点不太好落脚
Lucia: People will have a hard time walking around.
Lucia: 现在这样应该啊
Lucia: Now, like this...
Lucia: 这还有一个袋子
Lucia: There's another bag here.
Lucia: 给他扫了吧
Lucia: Let's sweep it up.
Alice:老板呢
Alice: Where's the boss?
Alice:老板什么时候录房间
Alice: When is the boss recording the room?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:什么没听清
Alice: What? Didn't hear clearly.
Lucia: 这个形状现在好神奇啊啊
Lucia: This shape is so amazing.
Alice:什么呀
Alice: What?
Lucia: 就是这个水龙头管子的形状
Lucia: It's the shape of this faucet pipe.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哎呀吃这个好上瘾呢
Alice: Wow, eating this is so addictive.
Lucia: afraid
Lucia: Afraid.
Lucia: 我怎么又找不到自己的手机了
Lucia: Why can't I find my phone again?
Alice:啊老板呢
Alice: Ah, where's the boss?
Lucia: 你现在开始扫房间了吗
Lucia: Are you starting to sweep the room now?
Jake:你要先把这个屋子收拾一下
Jake: You need to clean up this room first.
Jake:跟大伙一起收拾
Jake: Clean it up with everyone.
Jake:惨不忍睹是吧
Jake: It's a mess, isn't it?
Jake:把这个电脑装起来
Jake: Pack up this computer.
Tasha: 怎么就剩了一个麦克风
Tasha: Why is there only one microphone left?
Tasha: 巴啦啦啦啦啦
Tasha: Ba la la la la la.
Tasha: 有没有可能我们首先需要一个打垃圾袋
Tasha: Is it possible that we first need a large trash bag?
Jake:大垃圾袋
Jake: A large trash bag.
Jake:但是呢
Jake: But...
Tasha: 哪里有
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:在哪里会有呢
Jake: Where would it be?
Jake:拿个箱子过来跟他们学怎么样
Jake: Bring a box over and learn from them, how about that?
Jake:你等着
Jake: Wait.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:你等着我去拿个箱子上来
Jake: You wait here, I'll go get a box.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:哎呀你好
Jake: Oh, hi there.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 这有一个浪费鬼
Tasha: There's a wasteful person here.
Shure: 我买了西瓜
Shure: I bought a watermelon.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Alright, thanks.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 大家切瓜吃瓜吧
Shure: Everyone, let's cut the watermelon and eat it.
Jake:好吃吃瓜多吃瓜
Jake: Sure, eat more watermelon.
Jake:音响收一收
Jake: Pack up the audio equipment.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 那要镇上吗
Shure: Should we chill the watermelon?
Shure: 那个西瓜
Shure: That watermelon.
Jake:huh
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 那西瓜要镇一下吗
Shure: Should we chill the watermelon?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 怎么镇
Shure: How do we chill it?
Shure: 好的收拾收拾
Shure: Alright, let's clean up.
Jake:哎呀捡钱了
Jake: Oh, found some money.
Jake:这个小架子是哪来的呀
Jake: Where did this small shelf come from?
Tasha: 他房间的
Tasha: From his room.
Jake:哦你房间有个小架子啊
Jake: Oh, you had a small shelf in your room?
Lucia: 对对本来是有个这样的小架子
Lucia: Yeah, there was this small shelf.
Lucia: 他实在是太难装饰好看了
Lucia: It was really hard to decorate nicely.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后我就换成一个小小的柜子
Lucia: So I replaced it with a small cabinet.
Lucia: 给他铺了一个那个啥
Lucia: And I laid something on it.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Lucia: 这个我就拿出来了
Lucia: So I took this out.
Jake:太妙了
Jake: That's fantastic.
Jake:然后给给薇薇用了
Jake: And then gave it to Tasha to use.
Lucia: 对然后昨天刚好可以用来放甜点
Lucia: Yes, and yesterday it was perfect for holding desserts.
Jake:太妙了呀
Jake: That's fantastic.
Jake:这个应该也是记录了下来
Jake: This should have been recorded.
Jake:在你们俩的眼镜中
Jake: In your glasses.
Lucia: 对应该是我搬出来的时候
Lucia: Yes, it should have been when I moved it out.
Lucia: 我记得我戴眼镜了
Lucia: I remember I was wearing glasses.
Lucia: 因为昨天上午我一直在装修房子
Lucia: Because I was decorating the house all morning yesterday.
Jake:妙啊妙啊妙啊
Jake: Wonderful, wonderful, wonderful!
Lucia: 现在是不是又要该收拾一下
Lucia: Is it time to tidy up again?
Jake:对二楼再收拾一下就可以
Jake: Yes, just tidy up the second floor a bit more.
Jake:就可以吃西瓜了
Jake: Then we can eat watermelon.
Jake:修硕买了几个西瓜
Jake: Shure bought a few watermelons.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没有几个西瓜
Jake: Not a few watermelons.
Lucia: 几个西瓜
Lucia: A few watermelons.
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没电了又
Jake: Power's out again.
Jake:啥时候买没关系
Jake: When to buy, it doesn't matter.
Jake:没关系
Jake: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Jake:刮刮乐没买到
Jake: Didn't get the scratch-off tickets.
Jake:买了个瓜这
Jake: Bought a watermelon instead.
Katrina: 好啦这个是不是要搬下去了
Katrina: Alright, should we move this downstairs?
Jake:上面应该5个吗 12345
Jake: There should be five upstairs, right? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Jake:弄下去两个
Jake: Move two downstairs.
Jake:这小马就放上面吧弄下去
Jake: Let's leave the pony upstairs, move it down.
Shure: 收拾一下
Shure: Tidy up a bit.
Jake:要搬下去两个
Jake: Need to move two downstairs.
Lucia: 啊怎么
Lucia: Huh, why?
Lucia: 他有影响到什么吗
Lucia: Did it affect anything?
Jake:他没有影响到什么
Jake: It didn't affect anything.
Jake:他就放了进去
Jake: He just put it in.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Shure: 你要扫楼了是吗
Shure: Are you going to clean the floors?
Jake:对我要扫楼
Jake: Yes, I'm going to clean the floors.
Jake:他这个这
Jake: This one, here.
Lucia: 这也可以放回我房间里
Lucia: This can go back to my room too.
Jake:那你觉得有什么区
Jake: Well, do you think there's a difference?
Jake:你你房间确实没什么区别
Jake: Your room really isn't any different.
Jake:你房间可以不扫
Jake: Your room doesn't need cleaning.
Jake:哈哈哈什么
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Jake:你刚刚说啥
Jake: What did you just say?
Lucia: 我说这个就是如果影响
Lucia: I said, if it affects anything...
Lucia: 你可以放回我房间里
Lucia: You can put it back in my room.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't affect anything.
Lucia: 因为我是在收拾
Lucia: Because I'm tidying up.
Lucia: 所以先把它拿出来了
Lucia: So, let's take it out first.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Jake:就是除了你的房间和厕所
Jake: Except for your room and the bathroom.
Jake:别的都有巨大的变化
Jake: Everything else has changed a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这个并列关系
Lucia: This parallel relationship.
Jake:不是事实是这么回事
Jake: No, the fact is, it's like this.
Lucia: 你是懂修辞的
Lucia: You understand rhetoric.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我是不是有个卡子还啊
Lucia: Do I still have a clip or...
Lucia: 对在这
Lucia: Right here.
Lucia: 算了先这样吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's leave it for now.